las vegas now this summer is all about
staying cool and enjoying good food and
you can do just that at carson kitchen
joining us with a taste of their new
summer menu is chef scott simon and
brandon young thank you guys for being
here yeah thank you for having us on it
smells good in here we got a lot of
fresh ingredients and let's just jump
right to it what are we making here well
i think for uh the overall look here
we're kind of doing a lot of lighter
stuff during the summer of course we all
know the heat out there is just
unrelenting at this point yes but one of
our favorites here is the watermelon
salad so in the watermelon salad we have
cucumber feta and uh onion
and then we just top that off in there
looks delicious
so refreshing we have a white balsamic
vinaigrette in there oh my gosh so very
very fresh
very vibrant and then a little bit of
mint on top to finish that off oh that's
a great garnish
beautiful very light like i said it's so
good for summer hot days you're walking
out on the streets stop on in for one
for sure yeah when it's 110 out the last
thing you want is a hot hot steaming
dish so maybe an excellent perfect thing
to start with what are some of the other
items we have here we have our uh our
seared veloso salmon so very good
farm-raised salmon outside of chile
we have our mango chili lime salsa on
there
and then a little bit of cilantro on top
again very fresh very vibrant dish and
over here is that a crispy yeah this is
a great for our vegan uh customers uh
it's got nothing in there we have kimchi
uh teriyaki on the bottom
a papaya slaw with carrots and cucumber
and then our tofu very very good yeah
you guys have a lot of great options and
hey you can't have food without some
drinks what are these cocktails we have
over here they look very refreshing they
are they are it's perfect for summer um
this one's gonna be our dodgy smash it
is our take on a classic whiskey smash
we do some really good bourbon a little
kiwi juice a couple other secrets
including some ancho reyes which is a
pepper flavored liqueur so it has a
really nice earthy flavor can i try a
tip of it
go ahead yeah yeah
so i gotta go for it okay well i'm
taking a sip of this one tell us about
this one over here too this one is our
shandy cheeks so it's a take on a
classic shandy which is just going to be
beer and lemonade so this one has peach
vodka and strawberry as well and then we
top it off with some of our local las
vegas big dog lager well i have to try
both to compare right it's only fair i
can't leave this one out tell me the
name of this again shandy cheeks candy
cheeks this is so fun okay cheers to
everyone okay where's the drinks first i
know
we only got two over here two for me
sorry guys
no you guys this is so much fun and this
is all delicious are all these items
available now yes they are
okay well be sure to go check out carson
kitchen they have a lot of delicious
stuff it smells amazing take my word for
it cocktails are delicious you guys
thanks for being here happy
summer well